the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi in today's lesson hopefully we will
begin to reap the rewards of our
digression into the subject of linear
algebra recall that in the last few
lectures what we have been dealing with
is the problem of inverting systems of
linear equations and what we would like
to do today is to tackle the more
general problem of inverting systems of
equations even if the equations are not
linear and with this in mind I simply
entitled today's lesson inverting more
general systems of equations and by way
of a very brief review recall that given
the linear system y1 equals a 1 1 X 1
plus etc a 1 and xn up to yn equals a n
1 X 1 plus etcetera a and then xn we saw
that that system was invertible meaning
what that we could solve this system for
the X's as linear combinations of the
Y's if and only if the inverse of the
matrix of coefficients of this system
exists and in terms of determinants
recall that that means if and only if
the determinant of the matrix of
coefficients is not 0 if the determinant
of the matrix of coefficients was 0 then
we saw that y1 up to Y n are not
independent in fact in that context
that's where we came to grips with the
concept of a constraint that the
constraint actually turned out to be
what the fact that the Y's were not
independent meaning that we could
express a linear combination of the Y's
equal to 0 so what situation will react
then given a linear system if the matrix
of coefficients does not have its
determinant equal to 0 the system is
invertible we can solve for the X's in
terms of the Y's if the determinant of
the matrix of coefficients is zeros the
Y's are not linearly independent in
other words the system is not invertible
and now what we would like
do is to tackle the more general problem
of inverting any system of equations and
by any I mean what now we have y1 is f
sub 1 of X 1 up to xn etc Y sub n is f
sub n of X 1 up to X n and now what
we're saying is we do not know whether
the FS are linear or not in fact if they
are linear we're back to as a special
case what we've tackled before but now
we're assuming that these need not be
linear and what we would like to do is
to invert this system assuming of course
that such an inversion is possible again
what do we mean by the inversion we mean
somehow we would like to know that given
the system of n equations in n unknowns
where the Y's are expressed explicitly
in terms of the X's can we invert this
and express the X's in terms of the Y's
either explicitly or implicitly that's
the problem that we'd like to tackle and
what we're going to use to tackle this
is our old friendly differential the
linear approximation again that
motivated our whole study of linear
systems in the first place remember we
already know that if y1 is a
differentiable function of x1 up to xn
that Delta y1 sub 10 is exactly equal to
the partial of F 1 with respect to x1
times Delta x1 plus etc the partial of F
1 with respect to X n times Delta xn and
in terms of reviewing the notation
because we will use it later in the
lecture notice that Delta Y 1 10 was
what we abbreviated to be dy 1 and that
Delta X 1 up to Delta xn are abbreviated
respectively as DX 1 up to DX n
generalization of what we did for the
differential in the case of one
independent variable and we went through
this discussion when we talked about
exact differentials in block 3 and in
this similar way we can of course
express Delta Y 2 10 etc and we can talk
about the linear approximation
alright not the true Delta wise now but
the linear part of the Delta wise the
Delta y1 sub tan or if you prefer Delta
y1 sub Lin Li M all right
and the key point now is what if the Y's
happen to be continuously differentiable
functions of the X's in the neighborhood
of the point X bar equals a bar in other
words x1 up to xn is equal to a-1 comas
etc up to a and x1 equals a 1 x2 equals
a2 etc then near that point what we're
saying is what that the error term goes
to zero very rapidly and as long as the
functions are continuously
differentiable it means what that the
change in Y is approximately equal to
the change in Y sub 10 so that what
we're saying is and remember this is
what motivated our linear systems in the
first place that Delta y1 is
approximately the partial of Y 1 with
respect to x1 evaluated when X bar is a
bar times Delta x1 plus etc the partial
of Y with respect to X n also evaluated
when X bar equals a bar times Delta X
sub n etc down to Delta Y sub n is
approximately equal to the partial of Y
sub n with respect to x1 times Delta x1
plus etcetera the partial of Y sub n
with respect to X sub n times Delta xn
where all of these partials are
evaluated specifically at the point X
bar equals a bar the point being what
that since we're evaluating all these
partials at a particular point every one
of these coefficients is a constant you
see in general these partial derivatives
are functions but as soon as we evaluate
them at a given value they become
specific numbers so this is now what on
the right hand side we have a linear
system and the point is that we are
using the fundamental result that we can
use the linear approximation as being
very nearly equal to the true change in
Y and it's in that sense that we have
derived our system of and linear
equations in n unknowns you see this is
a linear system
the approximation again let me emphasize
that because it's very important the
approximation hinges on the fact that
what this is exactly equal to would be
Delta Y 110 etcetera Delta Y sub n but
we're assuming that these are close
enough in a small enough neighborhood of
X bar equals a bar so that we can make
this particular statement so this is a
linear system and because of this linear
system we're back to our special case
that this system is invertible if and
only if the determinant of the
coefficients matrix coefficients is not
zero and what does that matrix
coefficient it consists of n rows and n
columns and the row is determined by the
subscript on the Y and the column is
determined by the subscript on the X so
we write that matrix as the partial of Y
sub I with respect to X sub J in other
words the I throw involves the Y's and
the J column the X right and that's
exactly then how we handle this
particular system okay quite
mechanically and let's just summarize
that then very quickly if F sub 1 etc
and F sub n are continuously
differentiable functions of X 1 up to xn
near X bar equals a bar then the system
y1 equals f1 of X 1 up to xn etc yn
equals F sub n of X 1 up to xn that
system is invertible if and only if the
determinant the N by n determinant whose
entry in the ice road J column is the
partial of y sub I with respect to X sub
J if and only if that determinant is not
0 now what does that mean to say it is
invertible it means that we can solve
for the X's in terms of the Y's now we
may not be able to do that explicitly
the best we may be able to do is to do
that implicitly
meaning this let me just come back to
something I said before to make sure
that there's no misunderstanding about
this what we're saying is that in this
particular linear system of equations as
long as this determinant of coefficients
is not 0 we can
explicitly solve for Delta x1 up to
Delta xn in terms of Delta y1 up to
Delta yn even if we may not be able to
solve explicitly for the X's in terms of
the Y's in other words the crucial point
is we can solve for the changes in X in
terms of the changes in Y and that is
implicitly enough to see what the X's
look like in terms of the Y's once we
know what the change of X looks like in
terms of the change in Y then we really
know what the change in what X itself
looks like in terms of the Y's even as I
say it may be implicitly rather than
explicitly at any rate this matrix is so
important that it's given a very special
name definition the matrix whose entry
in the I throw J column is the partial
of Y sub I with respect to X sub J is
called the Jacobian I put matrix in
quotation marks here because some people
refer to the Jacobian meaning of matrix
other people call the Jacobian the
determinant of the Jacobian matrix I'm
not going to make any distinction this
way it'll be clear from context usually
when I say the Jacobian I will mean the
Jacobian matrix
I might sometimes mean the Jacobian
determinant and so to avoid ambiguity I
will hopefully say Jacobian matrix when
I mean the matrix and Jacobian
determinant when I mean the determinant
but should I forget to do this or should
you read a textbook where the woods are
Cobian is used without the proper noun
after it it should be clear from context
which is meant but at any rate that's
what we mean by the Jacobian of y1 up to
Y n with respect to x1 up to xn and this
Jacobian matrix is often abbreviated by
you either right J for Jacobian of y1 up
to Y n over x1 up to xn or else you use
a modification of the partial derivative
notation and you you sort of read this
as if it said the partial of Y 1 up to
yn divided by the partial of X 1 up to
xn and again there is the same analogy
between why this notation was invented
and why the notation dy / DX was
invented but in terms of giving you a
general overview of what we're
interested in I think I would like to
leave the discussion of why we write
this in a fractional form to the
homework in other words be as either a
supplement to the learning exercises or
else as part of the supplementary notes
in one form or another we will take care
of all of the computational aspects of
how one handles the Jacobian but what I
wanted to do now was to emphasize how
one uses the Jacobian matrix and
differentials to invert systems of n
equations and n unknowns and I will use
the technique that used right in the
textbook and which is part of the
assignment for today's unit the example
that I have in mind I'll simply pick the
usual case N equals 2 so things don't
get that messy using again the standard
notation when one deals with two
independent variables let u equal x
squared minus y squared let V equal to X
Y let's suppose now that I would like to
find the partial of X with respect to u
treating V as the other independent
variable you see again I want to review
this thing when I say find the partial
of X with respect to u holding V
constant it is not the same as finding
the partial of Y or respect to X from
here and then just inverting it namely
the partial of Y or respect to X here
assumes that Y is being held constant
and if you then invert that recall that
what you're finding is the partial of X
with respect to u treating Y as the
other variable we want the partial of X
with respect to u treating U and V as
the pair of independent variables Y
because that's exactly what you mean
by inverting this system this system as
given expressed as U and V in terms of
the pair of independent variables x and
y and that what you'd like to do is
express the pair of variables x and y in
terms of the independent variables U and
V assuming of course that u and V are
indeed independent very
the mechanical solution is simply this
using the language of differentials we
write down D U and DV namely D U is what
the partial of U respect to x times DX
plus the partial of U respect to Y times
dy and from the relationship that you
equals x squared minus y squared we see
that D U is 2x DX minus 2y dy similarly
since the partial of V with respect to X
is 2 y and the partial of V with respect
to Y is 2x we see that DV is 2y DX plus
2x dy if we now assume that this is
evaluated at some point x0 y0 what do we
have over here once we've picked out a
point x0 y0 to evaluate this at and i
left out that because it simply would
make the notation too long but I'll talk
about that more later assuming that
we've evaluated this at a particular
fixed value of x and y we have what D U
is some constant times DX plus some
constant times dy DV is some constant
times the X plus some constant times dy
in other words D U and DV are expressed
as linear combinations of DX and dy we
know how to invert this type of a system
assuming that it's invertible sparing
you the details what I'm saying is what
I could multiply say the top equation by
x the bottom equation by Y and when I
add them the terms involving dy will
drop out and I will get XD u plus y DV
is 2x DX plus 2y DX in other words twice
at 2x squared I'm multiplying the top
equation by X the bottom equation by Y
so the right hand side here becomes 2x
squared DX plus 2y squared DX which is
twice x squared plus y squared DX I now
divide both sides of the equation
through by twice x squared plus y
squared I wind up with the fact that DX
is x over twice the quantity x squared +
y squared du u + the quantity Y over
twice x squared plus y squared DV
recall that I also know by definition
that DX is the partial of X with respect
to u times D U plus the partial of X
with respect to V times DV recalling
from our lecture on exact differentials
that the only way to differentials in
terms of the U and DV can be equal is if
they're equal coefficient by coefficient
I can therefore equate the two
coefficients of D U to conclude that the
partial of X with respect to U is x over
two times the quantity x squared plus y
squared in fact I can get the extra
piece of information even though I
wasn't asked for that in this problem
that the partial of X with respect to V
is y over twice the quantity x squared
plus y squared
by the way observe purely algebraically
that the only time I would be in any
difficulty with this procedure is if x
squared plus y squared happen to equal
zero in other words if x squared plus y
squared happened to equal zero then to
divide through by twice x squared plus y
squared is equivalent to dividing
through by zero and division by zero is
not permissible in other words somehow
or other I must take into consideration
that I am in trouble
if x squared plus y squared is zero
notice by the way that the only time
that x squared plus y squared can be
zero is if both x and y is zero and that
means again that somehow or other at the
point zero comma zero in a neighborhood
of the point zero over the point zero
comma zero in a neighborhood of the
origin I can expect to have a little bit
of trouble now again the main aim of the
lecture is to give you an overview the
trouble that comes in at the origin will
again be left for the exercises in a
learning exercise we will discuss just
what goes wrong if you take a
neighborhood of the origin to discuss
the change of variables u equals x
squared minus y squared V equals 2xy
suffice it to say for the time being
that the system of equations u equals x
squared minus y squared V equals two XY
is invertible in any neighborhood of a
point x0
comma y0 except in that one possible
case when you have chosen as the point
x0 y0 the origin at any rate to take
this problem away from a specific
concrete example that we've been talking
about and to put this in terms of a more
general perspective let's go back more
abstractly to the more general system
system let's suppose now that U and V
are any two continuously differentiable
functions of x and y let u be f of XY
let V equal G of XY and what we're
saying is if you pick a particular point
x0 comma y0 then by mechanically using
the total differential we have that D U
is the partial of F with respect to X
evaluated at x0 y0 times DX plus the
partial of effort respect to Y evaluated
x0 y0 times dy we have that DV is the
partial of G with respect to X evaluated
at x0 y0 times DX plus the partial of G
with respect to Y evaluated x0 y0 times
dy what is this now this is a linear
system of two equations in two unknowns
D U and DV are linear combinations of DX
and dy the key point being again that's
why I put this in here specifically with
the X sub 0 and the Y sub 0 the key
point is that as soon as you evaluate a
partial derivative at a fixed point the
value is a constant not a variable so
this is what a linear system we have D U
as a constant times the X plus a
constant times dy DV is a constant times
the X plus a constant times dy again to
make a long story short I can solve for
DX in terms of D U and DV I can solve
for dy in terms of D U and DV provided
what that my matrix of coefficients does
not have its determinant equal to 0 and
to review this more explicitly so you
see the mechanics all I'm saying is to
solve for DX I can multiply the top
equation by the partial of G with
respect to Y evaluated
zero I can multiply the bottom equation
by minus the partial of F with respect
to Y evaluated x0 y0 and then when I add
these two equations the dy term will
drop out again leaving the details for
you it turns out that DX is what the
partial of G with respect to Y and I've
abbreviated this again this means what
evaluated x0 y0 times D you minus the
partial of effort respect to Y at X 0 y
0 times DV over the partial of effort
respect to x times the partial of G with
respect to Y minus the partial of F with
respect to Y times the partial of G with
respect to X and notice of course that
this denominator is precisely our matrix
of coefficients F sub X F sub y G sub X
G sub y and the only place I've taken a
Liberty here is to use the abbreviation
of leaving out the x0 y0 and the key
point is what the only place I am going
to get in trouble is if this denominator
happens to be 0 in the 2 by 2 case in
other words in the case of two equations
and two unknowns notice that we can see
explicitly what goes wrong when the
determinant of coefficients is 0 the
determinant of coefficients is just this
denominator and when that denominator is
zero we're in trouble
in other words the only time we cannot
invert this system the only time we
cannot find Delta X and Delta Y in terms
of D U and DV is when this determinant
is 0 now you see I think this is pretty
straightforward stuff the textbook has a
section on this as you'll be reading
shortly it is not hard to work this
mechanically and then the question that
comes up is how come when you pick up a
book and advanced calculus there's
usually a huge chapter on jacobians and
inversion why isn't that this simple in
the advanced textbooks why can we have
it in our book this simply but yet in
the advanced book why is there so much
more to this beneath the surface the
answer
behind all of this is quite subtle fact
the major subtlety is this that is that
the notation D U and for that matter DV
or DX or dy or dx1 dx2 whatever you're
using here is ambiguous and it's
ambiguous for the following reason
recall how we define the meaning of the
symbol D u if u is equal if we're
assuming that U is expressed as a
function of the independent variables x
and y then by D u we mean Delta u tan on
the other hand if we inverted this D U
now in other words women by inverted
this what I mean first of all is if we
assume now that x and y are expressed in
terms of U and V for example suppose X
is some function H of U and V what does
D you mean now notice that now U is
playing the role of an independent
variable for the independent variable D
U just means Delta U in other words by
way of a very quick review notice that
if we're viewing you as being a
dependent variable then D u means Delta
u tan but if we're viewing you as being
an independent variable then D u means
Delta u and consequently the results
that we're using hinge very strongly
then in other words the inversion that
we're using hinges very strongly on the
requirement in other words the inversion
requires the validity of interchanging
Delta U and Delta u 10 etc now let me
show you what that means more explicitly
let's come back to something that we
were talking about just a few moments
ago from a completely mechanical point
of view given that nu equals f of X Y
and V G of X Y we very mechanically
wrote down that D U was f sub X DX plus
F sub y dy DV was G sub X DX plus G sub
y dy and then we just mechanically
solved for DX in terms of D U and DV my
claim is is that if we translate this
thing if we translate this thing into
the language of
Delta use Delta X's Delta u tans Delta X
tans etc what we really said was what
that Delta u tan was the partial of f
with respect to x times Delta X plus the
partial of F with respect to Y times
Delta Y and Delta V Tan was the partial
of G with respect to x times Delta X
plus the partial of G with respect to Y
times Delta Y and then when we eliminate
a delta Y by multiplying the top
equation by G sub y and the bottom
equation by minus F sub y and adding
what we found was how to express Delta X
and catch this this is the key point
what we did was is we expressed Delta X
as a linear combination not of Delta U
and Delta V but of Delta u tan and Delta
V tan you see notice that the result
that we needed to have to be able to use
differentials was not this but this see
we found this not Delta X 10 equals G Y
Delta u minus F sub y Delta V over F sub
X G sub y minus F sub y G sub X to be
able to say to invert this required that
this was the expression that we had yet
the expression that we were really
evaluating was this one in fact let me
come back for one moment and make sure
that we see this you see notice again
that the subtlety of going from here to
here and inverting never shows us that
we're then to change the rows of U and V
from being the dependent variables to
the independent variables so the reason
that there is so much work done in
advanced textbooks under the heading of
inverting systems of equations is to
justify that being able to switch from
Delta X 2 Delta X tan R from Delta u tan
to Delta u as we see fit whenever it
serves our purposes the validity of
being able to do that hinges on this
more subtle type of proof that as far as
I'm concerned goes beyond the scope of
texts other than for the fact that in
the learning exercises I will find
excuses to bring up all of the
situations that bring out where the
theory is important in other words there
will not be proofs of these more
difficult things not because the proofs
aren't important but from the point of
view of what we're trying to do in our
course these proofs tend to obscure the
mainstream of things so what I will do
in the learning exercises is bring up
places that will show you why the theory
is important at which point I will
emphasize what's the result of the
theory is without belaboring you and be
leading you with the proofs of these
things at any rate what I'd like to do
now next time is to give you an example
where all of the material of the blocks
of material that we've done now on
partial derivatives are sort of pulled
together very nicely but at any rate
we'll talk about that more next time and
until next time goodbye
funding for the public
of this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate